rangera tout est bienvenu sur social
buzz alors aujourd'hui je voulais vous
présenter à l'avant cursus universitaire
est particulièrement vous expliquer les
raisons pour lesquelles j'ai failli ne
jamais entrer en doctorat de sociologie
donc quand j'étais enfant même au
collège et au lycée je voulais être
journaliste ou prof de français
ça a toujours été mes deux mi temps de
rêve et donc ça que c'est naturellement
lui aussi orienté en filière littéraire
pour le bac et ensuite en hypokhâgne et
en cale en fait j'ai fait pas forcément
prêtes à aller directement en fac de
lettres j'avais l'impression que j'avais
pas encore exploré vraiment certains
aspects de certaines disciplines
certaines matières extra
donc j'ai préféré partir de là quelque
chose d'assez gérer la liste c'est à
dire la prépa donc j'ai fait hypokhâgne
et khâgne et ça a été des années tout
simplement pas plus franchement on va
pas se mentir la province super dur mais
moi ça m'a énormément apporté en termes
de culture générale de rigueur de
d'autodiscipline et surtout ça avait
envie de découvrir certaines matières
autrement par exemple j'ai réalisé que
la littérature j'adorais ça mais que je
ne voyais pas forcément en faire mon
métier à long terme par contre à
linverse j'ai eu une révélation pour le
géographe c'est une matière qui
clairement au lycée m'a jamais paru
vraiment passionnante si j'aimais bien
plus en plus entre eux pas j'ai tout
simplement adoré c'était une révélation
de voir avec tout autour de nous est
géographie d'observer à la fois la
formation des territoires ddt et
l'impact de l'agriculture sur le paysage
la manière dont la vie humaine façonne
aussi son environnement coup et
passionnée par tout l'environnement
bref que des choses passionnantes et
elle est à la fois l'histoire des
langues est un peu de science durland la
géologie extra bref j'ai tout simplement
fan de mon prof de géographie je vais
vous avouer
et j'ai adoré la jeune date du coup
assez nationalement je me suis
représenté en khâgne spécialité histoire
géo pour passer les concours de l s et
es ce moment là j'ai commencé à me dire
que c'était peut-être possible que je me
retrouve à faire
le ls jusque là en fait l'école normale
supérieure ça n'allait pas forcément
vraiment tenté je faisais créer une
prépa plus pour découvrir d'autres
matières mais jamais je te dis vraiment
de là naissent à pleurer dans l'objectif
final est à ce moment là je me suis dit
que non il fallait faire que je passais
concours de manière sérieuse mais le
goût de condom à scolaire est vraiment
très dur il ya très peu de réussite et
j'ai simplement juste il fallait pas que
je me fasse des portes
donc j'ai passé d'autres concours je me
suis inscrite en fac à côté en
géographie et j'ai passé notamment le
concours des instituts d'études
politiques c'est-à-dire de sciences po
mais des sciences po dit de province
j'aime pas du tout cette appellation
mais les sciences po de région andrew
sciences po qui n'est pas avare et un
amant surprise j'ai été prise donc je me
suis retrouvé à accepter à sciences po
lille qui est en plus mon premier choix
donc j'étais ravie et assemble abbas et
j'ai aussi dû renoncer à la géographie
pur et dur à ce moment là chez nous à
l'hagiographie parce que j'avais encore
le lancement j'avais de choses à voir je
me dis que je pouvais revenir vers la
géographie
si l'horizon se présentait en fait ils
seront tous là je réalise t pour passer
la grève
et là on proposait sciences po et par
voyage et les littéraires
on m'a toujours dit que si on faisait l
on pourrait jamais entré chez spotify
part de l'économie jamais fait et on me
voit là admises à sciences po incroyable
et donc voilà à sciences po à moins que
l'économie du droit sans dire la galère
on n'avait jamais fait mais je découvre
plein d'autres matières
la sociologie politique sujet toral
relations internationales tout ce qui
concerne l'organisation de politique de
l'union européenne externe
c'était passionnant et plein de choses
différentes et à la fin de la deuxième
année de sciences po il faut partir en
troisième année à l'étranger en mobilité
internationale
choisi la turquie y'a pas de raison
particulière pour laquelle choisi la
turquie
c'était plutôt une attirance inexpliqué
voilà j'ai atterri à istanbul et j'ai
tout de suite adoré afolabi 6 et
l'enseignement dans mon université
quitté l'université anglophone où
j'étais département de science politique
et j'avais des cours au site de théorie
du genre et de théorie de l'action en
potiches développement et ça a été les
grandes découvertes et j'ai adoré ça
marc véron de nouveaux horizons
généralisée de faire un stage je
travaille dans une ong qui avaient des
programmes en gros de soutien pour des
femmes qui étaient illettrés ou je
n'avais pas accès facilement à des
structures publiques et s'est exposé qui
est très importante puisque dans le
chanterai chance pour je voulais
vraiment exploré le plus surcoté ong
aide humanitaire et c est en fait en
faisant ce stage est ravi que le monde
des ong bas c'était pas pour moi
tout simplement j'ai réalisé que j'étais
pas forcément à l'aise avec en fait avec
nous et quand ce négatives à long terme
qui pouvait y avoir à la chute d'une ong
ou encore le système de financement qui
parfois battus peu compliqué puisque
toutes les parties prenantes ont leur
mot à dire sur les programmes en place
et le fait en plus à côté de faire des
cours où je lisais les critiques
féministes et autres de l'action des ong
l'action militaire et même mais en
général les critiques des politiques de
développement
eh bien j'ai réalisé que c'était pas
pour moi donc en ce sens sur qui je
savais que je voulais tourner et que je
voulais essayer d'y vivre ma carrière
pour autant j'étais un peu perdue parce
que je ne voyais pas de tous vos sens
drac et du coup j'ai passé les moues
cour d'une école de journalisme à 1000
et kateri réputé qui me faisait rêver
plus jeunes et en passant mon boulot
j'ai réalisé que finalement ce n'était
pas pour moi et je suis encore
évidemment maintenant très intéressé par
les du journalisme mais je me dis que
c'est peut-être pas le mieux pour ma
carrière est en fait j'avais la
sensation qu'ils avaient quelque chose
doute pour moi comme un autre chemin je
sais pas donc je suis entré hamas en
master à sciences po
je suis en train de master conflit et
développement donc là je te regarde
le wise et xterra j'étais un peu perdu
au niveau de mon orientation
professionnelle
je me demande à son linge et si j'avais
pas m'orienter plus tôt par les grandes
organisations internationales
mais j'étais pas très sûr j'ai un peu du
mal à repérer et est venu le moment de
rédiger le mémoire de master à sciences
po et j'ai eu énormément de chance
puisque mon mémoire a été dirigée par
une enseignante qui à l'époque
d'ailleurs est doctorante en fin de
thèse et qui était déjà très fine
connaisseuse des théories féministes en
sciences politiques et ça a été la
révélation le fait en fait de pouvoir
faire du terrain pour moi c'était ce que
je voulais faire en journalisme aller
voir les gens sur le travail les
interroger les enregistrer prendre des
photos l alizé toutes ces données est en
fait le confronter à des outils
théoriques
j'ai réalisé que c'était ça que je
voulais faire c'était voir comment
comprendre la réalité grâce à la science
clairement c'était pas une année facile
de la casnos pau entre les nombreux
cours les partiels et puis le travail
que j'avais à côté des études plus de
mémoire c'était vraiment beaucoup de
travail tout simplement
mais j'étais vraiment très épanouie et
surtout que j'avais trouvé ma voie
je ferme la recherche sauf que là encore
quelque chose de lui mettre des bâtons
dans les roues
j'ai réalisé que si je continuais mon
master à son tour tel qu'il était je
n'aurais pas d'autonation l'entrée en
doctorat de mme inscrits en doctorat
car il faut avoir un master 2 de
recherche et non un master professionnel
donc j'ai demandé une dérogation auprès
sciences po pour pouvoir suivre mais
pour la distance est inscrit à
l'université paris diderot pouvoir
suivre des enseignements de master 2 de
recherche en sociologie
du coup cette année là je suis n 2
master 2 en même temps là aussi le temps
de dire qu'il y avait du travail et j'ai
intégré un master qui était tout
simplement génial c'était un master 2
recherche en sociologie et en
anthropologie qui s'appelle genre et
changement social et politique
perspective transnationale
voilà
le nom me fait rêver en tout cas je sais
pas vous mais j'ai adoré ce master qui
me permettait en fait d'avoir une solide
connaissance de toutes les théories
féministes en sciences sociales
sociologie et aussi de prendre en compte
ces critiques quand elles viennent de
différents pays d'amérique latine du
moyen-orient et c est forcément comme
moi je vais travailler en turquie
c'était parfait d'autant plus qu'une des
fondatrices de ce masters qui a une
grande chercheuse qui est aujourd'hui ma
directrice de thèse et bien être
spécialiste de l'iran est également
qu'ils connaissent ou de nature donc
j'étais toute heureuse de pouvoir
également faire un deuxième mémoire de
recherche qui aurait pu être le
cauchemar dont bon nombre de mes
camarades de classe et bien moi j'en ai
fait un deuxième
et ça a été encore plus instructif tout
simplement j'ai adoré je suis reparti
sur un autre terrain mais toujours avec
les problématiques similaires et j'ai
été un terrain voire plus long avec une
perspective de genre beaucoup plus
assumer et j'ai adoré ce travail la
première fois et je soutiens mon mémoire
tout se passe bien
sauf que entre l'inter et le passé et je
ne peux pas m'inscrire en doctorat donc
je vous retrouve avec deux masters dans
la poche mais pas de doctorat en vue et
donc à ce moment là le l'apéritif du dr
commence un peu à s'éloigner
malheureusement donc je me retrouve
caissière chez décathlon guides
touristiques sur des bateaux à paris je
pars sur un coup de tête
investir toutes mes économies dans des
cours intensifs de turcs à istanbul
break
cette année là j'étais un peu perdu mais
pendant ce temps le fil rouge c'est que
j'ai construit mon projet de texte d'une
étape super importante pour un doctorat
si le fait d'avoir un projet thèse avec
une problématique un monta de la
recherche
en fait il faut montrer ce qu'on veut
apporter qu'est ce qui nous pose
problème dans l'observer et comment on
va voir le montrer et faire des
hypothèses sur les résultats et spira et
ce projet on le soumet à l'école
doctorale de notre université pour
espérer obtenir un contrat doctoral
c'est à dire une rémunération
zhai permettre de financer trois années
de thèse sauf que à ce moment là que je
n'ai pas obtenu ce contrat semblement
les places sont chères il a très très
peu de contrats de tous vos notamment
dans la recherche en sciences sociales
et je n'ai pas obtenu ce contrat et donc
j'ai encore cru que la thèse abc
mais j'étais tellement déterminé à
rentrer en phase qui me parle me trouver
une solution donc j'ai grandi j'ai pris
un boulot dans le secteur privé parce
que bon il faut bien remplir les caisses
et le travailler pendant un an dans le
secteur privé en essayant de continuer à
m'accrocher au monde universitaire à
travailler pour pouvoir faire ma tête
donc je continue à lire j'ai continué à
essayer de rester proche dans le terrain
et surtout j'ai continué à répondre par
des appels à candidatures pour des
contrats doctoraux pour des bourses etc
et j'ai obtenu une bourse et en plus
quel beau c la branche dont je bénéficie
aujourd'hui et je suis extrêmement fier
et seront heureuses de pouvoir en
bénéficier
elles permettent à temps plein en
turquie et ça c'était vraiment
l'objectif final à la fin de mon cv j'ai
décidé de passer à pantin sur ma thèse
et c'était vraiment une victoire parce
qu'il ya plein de gens qui m'ont dit
mais tu vas voir mon pote soit un
secteur privé tu voudras pas retourner
vers la recherche dans la précarité du
milieu universitaire qui est
malheureusement une réalité mais en fait
je savais que c'était ça que je voulais
faire et j'ai décidé d'insister
donc voila depuis décembre à temps plein
sur ma thèse chez également heureuse
épanouie je pense que ça sent même pas
de vidéo que j'ai commencé à vous faire
en tant que le début de ma thèse en
finale le matin ces jeux là commence pas
maintenant vous l'aurez compris ça fait
bientôt deux ans que je construis mon
projet que je lis mais évidemment je
suis pas à temps plein sur la tête et il
entend pas on commence c'est tout ce que
je voulais vous dire à cette idée hausse
et que j'ai pas toujours su que je
voulais être chercheuse j'ai pas
toujours su que c'était la sociologie
qui m'intéressait pas s'est pas plaint
chemins différents
certains penseront que je me suis perdu
mais au contraire c'est dans
l'exploration de plein disciplines
différentes et c'est là que j'ai trouvé
ce qui était vraiment important pour moi
et au final quand je me dis que je
voulais te journalistes ou pour des
français je vois comment j'ai pu en
arriver à un doctorat en sociologie et à
ma volonté de devenir chercheuse et
pourtant son enseignante chercheuse donc
nous allons vous dire que les doctorants
des profils très divers si je pars de
recevoir un doctorat ne lâchait pas et
continue et durable de persévérer et
tous les chemins sont bons le tout c'est
de savoir quels sont les critères
vraiment essentiel pour pouvoir entre un
doctorat et puis j'espère
cette vidéo vous aurez intéressé que
vous comprenez un petit peu plus long
bar cours d'un parcours qui depuis mon
bac a quand même duré huit ans n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner à la chaîne pour la
prochaine vidéo de sociologie et puis
vous pouvez aussi me suivre sur
instagram
le lien est en barre d'infos et en
attendant je vous souhaite une très
bonne journée et à bientôt sur ce sol
russe
[Musique]